-Senate Republicans filibustered
a crucial package
of election reforms
and then two Democrats
joined them
in blocking changes
to the filibuster
that would've allowed
voting rights legislation
to pass with a simple majority,
all of which came
on the same day Joe Biden
held a marathon press conference
to jump-start his agenda.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, last night was not
a great night for democracy.
Senate Republicans blocked
much-needed election reforms
essential to safeguarding
our democracy
and then, two Democrats,
Joe Manchin and Kyrsten Sinema,
helped them block rule changes
that would've allowed
the voting rights bill to pass.
And, because Manchin and Sinema
had already announced
their opposition,
the votes were so anticlimactic,
even news anchors
had a hard time
pretending there was
much suspense.
♪♪
-So here's our
breaking news right now.
The effort to change the
filibuster rule in the Senate
failed, as expected.
-Hey, CNN, as a rule,
you can't put the words
"breaking news"
and "as expected"
in the same sentence.
[ Laughter ]
It's like running a banner
during New Year's Eve saying...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Who gave them tequila?!"
[ Laughter ]
So, to recap, Senate Republicans
representing a minority
of Americans
filibustered voting rights
legislation favored
by a majority of Americans
which would've passed,
if not for the filibuster.
So, Senate Democrats,
who represent
a majority of Americans,
then tried to change
the filibuster,
but they couldn't
because two Democrats
who voted
for the voting rights bill
also voted to keep
the filibuster,
which prevents them from passing
the voting rights bill
they support.
And let me be clear --
that is a sentence
that makes no [bleep] sense,
whatsoever.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I checked three times with Wally
to make sure
the cue cards were correct
and he said they were,
although he did misspell
the word filibuster.
-Sorry, Seth.
That's a tough word.
-"And the werd 'werd'"?
-Hey, baby, I got to stay
on-camera, somehow.
Wink!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I hope, at the very least,
this is a moment when we can
step back to fully digest
just how ass-backwards
our system is.
Anytime you try to explain
American democracy to someone,
you sound like an Amazon Echo
that got dropped in the toilet.
Alexa!
Alexa, what's a democracy?
-A democracy is a system
of government
where a majority of people vote
for something
and then a small group
of senators ignore them
and do whatever the [bleep]
they want.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, Alexa, whoa!
Watch the language, Alexa!
-Sorry, Seth.
I'm just so [bleep] [bleep]
over this mother[bleep]
filibuster cluster[bleep]
-Okay.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, hey, hey, Alexa.
Hey, Alexa, while I have you,
are you recording
and saving everything I say
in the privacy of my own home?
-I, well, um, sorry.
I have to take this call.
It's my, um, mom.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
I knew it!
It was sad, but predictable,
that Republicans would torpedo
basic voting rights legislation,
but what's
especially infuriating
is that two Democrats,
Manchin and Sinema,
announced that they would
join Republicans
in shooting down rule changes
that would've allowed the bill
they say they support to pass.
In fact, Manchin announced
his opposition
to changing the filibuster rules
in yet another grandstanding
floor speech yesterday,
where he said a bunch
of meaningless nonsense
next to a big old poster.
-The Senate has followed
its own rulebook
when making changes
that affect legislative debate.
We've changed rules over --
We have all talked
about how many times
rules have been changed.
We've changed them,
but we changed them
with the rules.
We didn't break the rules
to change the rules.
I cannot support such a perilous
course for this nation
when elected leaders are sent
to Washington
to unite our country,
not to divide our country.
We're called the United States,
not the Divided States.
-Dude,
you're from West Virginia.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You're
literally from a divided state.
But, yes,
the country is called
the United States,
not the Divided States,
which is truly
a searing insight.
Where'd you get that nifty
saying...?
[ Laughter ]
Also, what's with the big old,
dumb poster?
Are we supposed to be reading
the sign while you talk?
I feel like I'm reading
the subtitles
during an episode
of "Succession,"
while also trying to watch
what happens,
which, in fairness, is what I do
because I sometimes have trouble
understanding Brian Cox
when he talks super fast
with a Scottish accent.
He should be a voice option
on your GPS.
[ As Cox ]
In 100 meters, take a left.
[Bleep] you.
Whatever.
I'm kidding, but seriously,
go right.
We're here.
[Bleep] off.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, please stop whining
about biparti--
You know what?
I'm realizing,
Alexa gets her language from me.
[ Laughter ]
She learned it from me, Dad.
Also, please stop whining
about bipartisanship.
First of all,
bipartisanship means
appealing to the other side,
not joining it,
and, when it comes to voting,
there's only one side.
Republicans are the ones
waging war on democracy.
You can't compromise with the
side that's doing the damage.
When you're putting out a fire,
you don't call
the fire department
and the arsonist,
and see what they can
work out together.
[ Laughter ]
Republicans are the ones
passing bills
across the country
along strict party lines
that would allow them
to suppress votes
and subvert future elections
and, if we don't do something
to stop them,
they're going to try
another coup.
What makes you think 2020 was
a one-off?
Do you think Donald Trump,
of all people, is going to say,
"Oh, well, that didn't work out.
Let's do it fair and square
next time"?
[ Laughter ]
The guy has never not cheated
at anything in his life.
When he gets his height
measured, he uses hydraulics.
[ Laughter ]
[ Whirring ]
[ As Trump ]
8'3", just like I thought.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I just have to decide
between the Knicks
and the Lakers.
[ Laughter ]
Also, it's just
mindnumbingly stupid
that Manchin and Sinema
keep saying they support
the actual voting rights
legislation,
but oppose taking the steps
to pass it,
as Senator Bernie Sanders
made clear
in a blistering speech
yesterday,
where he called out Manchin
and Sinema specifically.
-Is changing the Senate rules
a radical idea?
Oh, my God!
First time in history,
we're about to do it.
Never been done before.
Oh, well, really, not quite, no.
As every member
of the Senate knows,
the rules get changed
on a fairly regular basis.
Nothing radical about it.
If you think
this bill makes sense
and if you're worried
about the future
of American democracy
and if you're prepared
to vote for the bill,
then why are you wasting
everybody's time
and not voting
for the rule change
that allows us to pass the bill?
You know, it's like
inviting somebody to lunch,
putting on a great spread,
and saying, "You can't eat."
[ Laughter ]
-And I, for one, am betting
Bernie has been
in that situation before.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, Bernie, you're here early.
The food is out,
but don't eat yet.
That's for after cocktails."
[ As Sanders ]
Oh, well, I wouldn't want
to upset the delicate
balancing act
you're undertaking
at this party.
Let me be clear --
I'm here to eat the food
and then get the hell out
[ Laughter and applause ]
before anyone shows up,
because my least favorite part
of a dinner party
is the other people. Now,
[ Laughter ]
if you will stay on the side,
I brought my own fork.
[ Laughter ]
This vote was a blow, of course,
not just to American democracy,
but to President Biden's agenda,
which he's desperately trying
to jump-start
as he enters year two
of his presidency.
Yesterday, he tried to hit the
reset button on his presidency
by holding a marathon
press conference
that set a presidential record.
-Today, President Joe Biden
marked one year in office
by holding his
10th press conference.
It ended up being the longest
in presidential history.
It lasted for one hour
and 51 minutes.
-Wow, I'm sorry,
but how is that possible?
It was longer than all
of Trump's press conferences?
I feel like every
Trump press conference
lasted either 10 seconds
or four days.
[ Laughter ]
Trump would either slink away
without taking any questions
or he'd stand there for hours
with his chest puffed out,
like one of those
jacked kangaroos
[ Laughter ]
challenging all the other
kangaroos to a fight.
And yet, somehow, Biden
set the record yesterday
when he defended
his administration's
accomplishments,
including the
American Rescue Plan and the
bipartisan infrastructure bill,
among others.
Although, I'm not sure he did
himself any favors when he said
one big reason he hadn't gotten
even more done in his first year
was that he hadn't expected
so much stonewalling
from Republicans.
-I did not anticipate
that there'd be such
a stalwart effort
to make sure that
the most important thing was
that President Biden
didn't get anything done.
-Why did you not
anticipate that?
[ Laughter ]
You're not a teenage idealist
who just got off the bus.
You're a 79-year-old man
who's been doing this
your entire adult life.
Were you not paying attention
during the Obama presidency
or were you just too busy
giving everyone finger guns,
like you were making sure
they had enough booze
at a house party?
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ] Randy!
You need another Mark?
How about you, Steve?
There's beer over there
in the cooler.
Help yourself.
I'm going skinny dipping later,
if anyone wants in.
Who's going to stop me,
the Republicans?
What, they are?
Why?
That's their sole purpose
in life?
[ Laughter ]
It's especially frustrating
because Biden does
have successes to celebrate.
For example,
the Biden administration
just launched
an easy-to-use website
where all Americans
can order free rapid tests
and the rollout
has been very smooth.
-The federal government's
website
for free COVID tests
has gone live.
In a soft launch,
the White House
began taking orders
for up to 4 tests per household.
-The federal government's
website to order rapid tests,
covidtests.gov, is live.
People can order up to four
tests per household,
which will ship
within 7 to 12 days.
-Just a day after the launch
of covidtests.gov,
about 27 million Americans
filling out
that online order form
for four free at-home
COVID tests per household.
-27 million people signed up
in one day. That's amazing.
The only way they could've
gotten a better response is
by offering the tests
via Wordle.
[ Laughter ]
Wordle might be a little hotter
in the office
than it is
in the world at large.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I really hope Democrats
take away a lesson from this --
it's easy to give people things
for free
that make their lives better,
and we should do it more often.
Just think how big
a success it is.
An easy-to-use
government program
where the website doesn't crash
and all you have to do is enter
your name and address
and you get an essential
healthcare product delivered
to you in the mail, for free,
in a few weeks.
That's like something you'd hear
about in Sweden or Denmark.
Americans aren't used
to getting things for free,
you know, unless they're shot
out of a cannon
at a basketball game.
[ Laughter ]
I'm half expecting to hear this
when I open the package
with my free test kits --
[ "Get Ready"-like tune plays ]
Now, that -- interesting fact --
is not the real song.
We couldn't afford the rights
to the real song
because we had to pay Wally
for his two lines tonight.
-Y'all ready for me?!
Boop!
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Oh, it's a crazy, crazy world
when you got Wordle here
and Wally here.
[ Laughter ]
Also, that was your third line,
Wally.
Now, all we can afford
is this --
[ Sad trombone plays ]
[ Laughter ]
Republicans are weaponizing
the big lie
that the 2020 election
was stolen
by passing a raft of laws
across the country
that would allow them
to suppress votes
and subvert future elections.
You can't say you're
for protecting democracy,
if you're not for taking
the steps necessary
to actually get it done.
If we don't do something now,
Democrats and anyone
who cares about democracy
are going to be hearing
a lot more of this --
[ Sad trombone plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.